hey there welcome to council of geeks
this is nathaniel Wayne I'm going to try
and do something that I have never done
before for this or anything else that I
can think of which is that I'm going to
do a live reaction video because the new
trailer for the star wars the force
awakens just came out I about 18 minutes
ago as of the time of this recording I
have not watched it yet i'm gonna watch
it right now and give my immediate
impression on it we'll see how this goes
i'm a sort of trim the the watching my
faith k don't i don't plan to intercut
the actual trailer with this so i may
not show you my help screw it let's just
do this I I don't know what I'm doing
clearly I haven't done this sort of
thing before anyways uh
I was starting out quiet I like that I
love that George
that looks like serenity which ship they
just flew off in the distance really did
it looks somewhere so soon into one
thing I've got nothing to fight for okay
it's not tattooing which means I guess
that's not most I see even though he
felt like that shot hello
and you stop
ok
worshiping dead bait Ernest big enough
okay there were stories about what
happened
I lovely music use I love that
Oh
okay fine
chatter
ah just didn't get Oh it froze up on me
for saying I gotta back it up should I
know
the real
oh it's calling to you
but finally a look of layout just
okay I like that I like it a lot I like
it more than I thought I would I'm kind
of glad i'm doing this video right now
because i think if i had more time to
think on it i would i would so shut up i
don't care about rebels i don't watch it
anyways um i'm glad i'm kind of
recording this right off the back
because i have a feeling if i stopped
and thought about it or watch to the
second time or a third time or a fourth
time or whatever that i would just start
picking it apart um but I like it I like
it a lot i am but i gotta say the my
favorite thing about that is the music
hearing just the Star Wars music and
again they continue to use awesome
wonderful immediately identifiable as
Star Wars pieces of music but they're
not doing the main star wars theme and
they're not doing you know the Imperial
March the stuff that everybody is is
almost kind of sick of at this point i
mean i'm not i could listen to it
forever but there is still using just
wonderful complete yes that is
absolutely star wars but it's not the
stuff that you always hear whatever you
hear star wars music and that i think
that just warms me more than anything
else other than that I mean it was just
it was nice it was cool i like the
pacing i like how it starts slow and
builds up it doesn't immediately start
hammering with your star wars i like the
little bits of Han Solo that we got I I
need to remind myself that I'm not
planning to cut this so I it when I
stumble not you'd normally want to do
these things I edit them so when I
stumble I pause I start over i'm trying
not to do that i'm trying to do this
uncut um I i I'd like to tear support of
all people the guy was like yeah hokey
religions and ancient weapons give me a
blaster is the one going it's true all
of it the dark side of the jedi the
force it's all true having him do that
that's just that's just nice that's cool
because it you know yeah we kind of were
assuming that that Luke who we still
have not seen aside from that hand on on
our to assuming that's him I'm still
assuming that it is but we don't know
that for certain um yeah we were it's
pretty much assumed that he's taking
some sort of obi-wan training position
but it's it's cool to have the former
doubter be like oh yeah oh yeah it's
real
it's all real and you know just seeing
him and chewy the-the-the some of the
space combat I liked it it looked good
some of it looked a little crowded like
not quite a prequel level crowded in
terms of you know the chips clan but I
mean there's something about how clean
the dog fights were in the original
trilogy and it was usually just you know
even in the massive space battles like
in Return of the Jedi you still when it
would focus in it we usually just be on
23 made like four at the most with the
exception of only one or two shots that
were like here's the swarm but Alice
focus in and I worry that we're not
going to get that because that really
was what gave it the dog fighting aspect
in that original trilogy so that that
makes me slightly nervous as soon as
this is what I'm talking about the the
the more distance I have from watching
it the more I'm picking it apart but
obviously if you watch this you watched
my face while I was playing I was
smiling it was good um yeah that's about
it because anything else i'm just gonna
start gathering my thoughts more and
i'll start picking it apart more but i
don't want a second guess this gut
reaction in this gut feeling which is
good it's positive I like it I thought
my initial reaction was gonna be more up
because that first teaser I was like
okay second teaser I loved it gave me a
literal chill down my spine this one
didn't quite hit that level but I
thought it was going to be a big drop
down for my reaction to the last one
it's not I like it I am I'm excited I am
genuinely excited for new Star Wars I
did not think that whatever happens so
yay everybody involved JJ Abrams Disney
Mukesh if you're still consulting at all
or at the very least for a passing long
and letting other people who work on it
everybody everybody involved thank you
now just don't drop the ball when I get
to the actual movie but so far yeah so I
guess that's it um if reaction is good
this maybe I'll do more stuff like this
I don't like staying up this late though
the release timing on this thing was
weird anyways um I guess that's it thank
you for watching have you seen the
teaser I really hope so i'm assuming
that you probably did whatever your
thoughts on it were drop something down
in the comments let's talk about it
please hit the subscribe button hey is
my first time plugging the subscribe
thing I always come assume people know
how to subscribe I never mention it
otherwise I don't know why I did now in
any case until next time this council is
adjourned